as numbers at those mass vaccination
sites are going down the southern nevada
health district
ramping up their vaccination efforts
smaller clinics are now popping up
across the valley
kate houston taking a look at how the
turnout could impact vaccination rates
and what health officials are doing to
draw people in our goal
is to get vaccine in arms a major push
by the health district to continue
vaccinating the community
so going to places like community
centers
senior centers places where people are
already
engaged in the community there dr
christina madison works with roseman
university which has overseen many
pop-up clinics since early april
now that large vaccination sites such as
cashman center and unlv will close next
week
dr madison says these pop-up clinics
will become
even more important meeting people where
they are
having these vaccine clinics and
locations where people like
know and trust you right so like that's
the number one thing that we need
to be able to overcome some of this
vaccine hesitancy
throughout the past week hundreds of
people have been vaccinated at smaller
clinics
we want to get up to that 60 we want to
make sure everyone's coming back for
their second dose we want to make sure
that people are fully protected
sara lugo with the southern nevada
health district says this outreach won't
end anytime soon with eight pop-up
clinics planned for next week
we really try and target those areas
where we do have our underserved areas
or where we see that we're lacking in
providing vaccinations in specific areas
now they're working on ways to bring
more people in roseman is considering
live
music we'll be helping out our local
artists that
have obviously been hit very hard during
the pandemic
and then also providing some
entertainment for people while they wait
for their vaccine or while they wait
during the observation period
kate houston 8 news now although
vaccination sites at cashman center and
unlv will close the convention center
will stay open right through june to
make vaccinations a bit more convenient
a drive-through clinic could be offered
as early as next week